tony hill et 7h50 sur radio classique
les phénomènes météorologiques extrêmes
comme le typhon des philippines vont-ils
se multiplier dans les années à venir
c'est la crainte exprimée hier par
l'organisation météorologique mondiale
qui relève par ailleurs que 2013 aura
été l'une des années les plus chaudes
depuis le milieu du 19e siècle bonjour
jean marc jancovici est associé de
carbone 4 présidents de six chiffres
project les lecteurs des échos peuvent
lire régulièrement vos chroniques sur
l'environnement et l'énergie
rien ne semble freiner réchauffement
climatique idées reçues ou réalité
annoncé tout à fait une réalité en fait
le changement climatique on a souvent
tendance à l'assimiler à une
augmentation de la température de l'air
il faut savoir qu'en premier lieu ça
s'assimile surtout à une augmentation de
la température de l'eau le changement
climatique en fait c'est un surplus
d'énergie que l'atmosphère envoie vers
la surface de la terre la surface de la
terre c'est surtout des océans et les
océans en magazines ainsi un surplus
d'énergie
il faut savoir que 90 % de l'énergie
supplémentaire que l'atmosphère envoie
vers la terre dans le cadre du
supplément d'effet de serre c'est ça qui
va dans les océans et pas du tout dans
l'atmosphère donc en fait les phénomènes
lents il se produit dans les océans et
il est doté d'une inertie absolument
considérable même si demain matin on
arrêtait la totalité des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre sur la planète les
océans continuerait à se modifier
pendant encore des siècles et des
millénaires de l'innovation de la
température des océans qui fait gonfler
ces mêmes océans et qui explique les
versions du niveau de l'absolu mans le
lolo quand elle chauffe se dilate et
c'est l'une des raisons qui fait que
l'élévation du niveau de la mer va se
poursuivre pendant des siècles e s que
tenter de stopper du moins de freiner le
réchauffement climatique donc les
émissions de dioxyde de carbone implique
des transformations économiques trop
importante aujourd'hui pour nos sociétés
pour qu'elles soient acceptées mise en
place par nos dirigeants
il ya un parallèle que j'utilise parfois
quand on essaye de parler du changement
climatique c'est le tabac savait au
moment où on commence à fumer c'est pas
là qu'on a les ennuis majeurs et au
moment où les ennuis majeurs sont là on
peut bien s'arrêter dessus mais ça
change plus grand chose
eh bien le changement climatique c'est
exactement pareil avec en plus cette
difficulté supplémentaire qu'on a
affaire à un processus inédit jamais il
ya eu sur terre 7 milliards d'hommes
utilisant un milliard de voitures etc et
donc avoir peur entre guillemets de ce
qui pourrait se passer plus tard relève
uniquement d'une construction
intellectuelle
alors c'est une construction à laquelle
personnellement je crois je crois
qu'elle est solide je crois qu'elle est
fournie par des gens qui travaillent
sérieusement de bonne foi j'en connais
un certain nombre
c'est absolument pas des activistes etc
mais il n'empêche que c'est avoir peur
de quelque chose qui ne s'est jamais
produit et c'est tout faire pour que ça
ne se produise pas et vous savez que
dans l'histoire des hommes lutter contre
ce genre de construction intellectuelle
et quelques ça fait partie des grandes
difficultés de la faire ce qui est
difficile c'est d'avoir une idée précise
des conséquences économiques en fait de
ces contraintes liées au réchauffement
climatique alors c'est souvent comme ça
qu'on décide d'agir ou de ne pas agir
dans la vie de tous les jours on voit
bien qu'on va décider par exemple de
souscrire ou pas une prime d'assurance
en fonction de ce qu'on risque plus tard
et en termes purement économique je
dirais que la prime d'assurance est le
meilleur parallèle qu'on puisse trouver
c'est à dire que vous allez payer tout
de suite et de manière certaine pour
vous couvrir contre quelque chose qui
est futur est incertain
c'est très exactement la mécanique de la
prime d'assurance alors la difficulté
par rapport à l'assurance c'est que dans
l'assurance vous savez combien ça vous
coûte si vous cassez votre voiture ou si
votre logement prend feu dans le domaine
du réchauffement climatique
il n'existe pas de raisonnement solides
qui permettent de dire le maximum des
dommages c'est 1000 milliards de dollars
10 mille milliards de dollars 100 mille
milliards de dollars il n'y a pas de
raisonnement solides qui permettent de
dire ça pour une raison très simple
c'est que la planète terre c'est ce qui
permet aux hommes d'avoir notamment une
activité économique la totalité de notre
économie ne fait que transformer des
ressources naturelles qu'on trouve sur
terre avec l'optique ne peut pas faire
grand chose
exactement et donc combien coûte la
disparition du stock qui nous permet
d'avoir nos activités productives et
bien on peut en discuter sympathiquement
au café et je pense qu'au bout d'une
heure on sera toujours pas d'accord sur
le montant
mais on peut vraiment donc pas agir du
tout avoir des leviers des estimations
pour contraindre les acteurs économiques
à modifier leur comportement alors ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que comme il n'ya
pas de borne supérieure aux dommages
possibles
personne n'est capable de dire
exactement ces mêmes la définition
mathématique de l'infini c'est à dire
que la définition de l'infini en
mathématiques c'est quelque chose auquel
vous n'êtes pas capable de donner une
bande supérieure
donc si les dommages sont
potentiellement infini à ce moment toute
action est justifié pour prévenir ces
dommages
et là on va rentrer dans un débat
économique qui est totalement différent
qui est un débat microéconomique c'est à
dire comment est ce que je range les
actions qui me permettent d'agir
efficacement contre les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre et là on est en train
en ce moment dans le monde de faire les
choses plutôt à l'envers c'est à dire
que les actions sont souvent suggéré de
meilleurs sentiments talent par des
activistes qui ont leur rôle pour eux à
jaillir secouer un peu le cocotier mais
qui sont pas nécessairement les mieux
placés pour avoir des bonnes idées sur
la réponse est ce qu'on a fait en europe
un exemple parmi d'autres en
subventionnant de manière massive les
renouvelables électriques intermittente
c'est justement non pas la première et
la dernière chose à faire si on pense
que le problème du changement climatique
et sérieux parce que c'est là que par
unité de capital investi on va déplacer
le moins de problèmes et non pas le plus
de problèmes
sinon si on pense qu'on est dans une
course contre la montre la rationalité
économique cdde alloués en premier le
capital là où ça vous réduit le plus de
problèmes et non pas le moins c'est à
dire il faut miser non pas sur les
renouvelables mais sur le nucléaire par
exemple alors les grandes marges de
manoeuvre sur lesquels il faut miser
parce que là vous avez de l'efficacité
par euros de capital investi c'est ce
qu'on appelle traditionnellement
l'efficacité énergétique en premier lieu
tout ce qui touche à la réfection des
bâtiments
c'est la diminution de la taille des
engins de transport qu'on utilise ça ne
changerait pas beaucoup la vie des gens
si vous passez d'une voiture à 6 litres
aux cents à une voiture à 2 litres au
cent sur l'eau dure un peu plus petit
qui va un peu moins vite ce qui a abouti
c'est un changement marginal dans la
manière dont on vit et ça va vous pouvez
l'obtenir avec des investissements qui
sont extrêmement réduits par rapport à
ce qu'on est en train d'investir dans
les nerfs électrique un chiffre un seul
l'allemagne aujourd'hui pour passer de 4
à 22 % d'électricité d'origine
renouvelable dans son mix électrique
donc bye l'angélique électrique et au
surplus non pas pour se passer du
charbon mais pour se passer du nucléaire
a mis 300 milliards d'euros sur la table
que le sac les allemands ont investi 300
milliards d'euros c'est-à-dire le coût
de réfection à 9 du parc nucléaire
français
rien que pour passer de 4 à 22% voilà
avec des engins qui vivent deux fois
moins longtemps qu'une centrale
nucléaire où un barrage
donc là aujourd'hui on est en train donc
dans le domaine de la production
électrique
oui effectivement faut à mon avis si on
est rationnel économiquement pas
commencer par mettre des panneaux
solaires partout et enfin
dans le domaine de l'industrie on va
dire qu'il ya un mélange à faire entre
l'efficacité énergétique et
l'électrification sans carbone des
processus tout ça il ya aujourd'hui une
manière d'aborder les problèmes qui
existent mais encore une fois alors
comme les gens sont peu familiers avec
cette manière d'aborder les problèmes
vous savez cette black célèbre qui est
qu'il n'est pas de problème qui ne
résiste durablement à une absence de
solution et comme aujourd'hui les
solutions sont souvent mises en avant
parce que c'est à eux que la presse
donne le plus souvent la parole par des
gens qui n'ont pas de rationalité
économique ou plus exactement pour qui
ça ne fait pas partie du cahier des
charges est bien le monde économique a
l'impression qu'on lui raconte des
salades et donc il n'a pas très envie
d'agir mais si on en a envie il ya plein
de choses à faire
bon la microéconomie donc au service du
réchauffement ou plutôt contre le
réchauffement climatique c'était l'idée
ce matin sur radio classique
merci beaucoup jean marc jancovici
devrait était avec nous et y est
l'invité de l'économie de radio
classique avec vendent elles vendent l1